welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and spider-man's status in the mcu
and the full effect of the memory wife
spell of spider-man no way home just got
two big updates one from an interesting
line from the sorcerer supreme wong in
she-hulk episode 3 and the other from
the re-release of no way home with a new
post-credit scene sequence that
justifies how the people in peter's life
don't remember him that's a depressing
answer apparently no one really gave
much of a [ __ ] about him to begin with
but the logic of what exactly wong
remembers calls into question how
powerful the source of supreme truly is
in the mcu and the entire hierarchy of
power over reality in the multiverse so
did wang just score himself a seat at
the table with the watcher and kang i
hope so this is after all the wong
cinematic unibong i got halfway through
the phrase and started to miss wong so i
brought it back in she-hulk episode 3
shamelessly brings in wong and who can
blame them to answer why he extracted
emil blonsky abomination from prison to
cameo and chongqi wong says he needed a
sparring partner as part of his
sorcerer's supreme training and he went
on to say i know what you're thinking
miss walters when i'm not erasing
everyone's memories not again this is a
reference to the runes of cough call the
memory wipe spell that steven strange
used in spider-man no way home to erase
the world's memory of peter parker that
spell travels the dark borders between
known and unknown reality it's too
dangerous we've used it for a lot less
do you remember the full moon party at
camertaj no exactly come on wong
hasn't he been through enough
just leave me out of this fine
fine now some have asked wait if the
memory white spell was successful by the
end of that film wouldn't everyone dr
strange and wong included forget that
any of this had happened like how much
exactly does wong in this case remember
well you could say that wong and she
hulk was referring to a past incident
the sorcerers wiped people's memories
about something but i doubt it when
strange asked wong if you remembered the
full moon party at camertaj wong did not
to him this spell is a kind of forbidden
third rail that he almost never uses
really the most prominent recent example
in the mcu would be the no way home
memory wipe spell which wong was at
least aware of happening even if the
effects of that spell redacted from his
memory who exactly the subject of that
spell was he did tell strange leave me
out of it and he gave strange explicit
permission as sorcerer's supreme to do
it his official blessing as the top
ranking towards her supreme now for
anyone who says that she-hulk might be
set before spider-man no way home no
disney plus's chronological playlist
lists it after multiverse of madness a
movie that made explicit reference to
the recent past incident with spider-man
we have experience of the multiverse
most recently there was an incident with
spider-man what man spider-man he has
the powers of a spider hence the name
and if you question the logic of that
line note that strange and wong do not
explicitly ever call spider-man peter
because that is how the spell works it
didn't wipe the full memory of a
superhero named spider-man from people's
minds it just erased the identity of
peter parker from their memories so
everyone still remembers the existence
of a spider-man and all the times this
masked vigilante named spider-man caught
criminals and helped the avengers it's
just the identity of who is under that
mask remains anonymous to them any
memory of an unmasked teenager named
peter parker is now fuzzy in their minds
and anybody who knew peter as peter no
longer really thinks about him now would
this include the moment in the snowed
out sanctum in which peter first came to
wong and strange asking them to do this
spell if wang now has no memory of peter
parker he shouldn't remember talking to
him in the sanctum or at least wang
might remember this moment that someone
had asked them to use the runes of cough
call spell but when he thinks back on
peter all he really sees is a fuzzed out
haze of just someone standing there and
he just knows as sorcerer's supreme that
they are now living in a post-spell
reality where everyone's in a kind of
amnesiatic state having these weird
redactions and mandela effects in their
minds and in general a really weird
relationship with reality itself as wong
said it's messy but this video is
brought to you by the ridge the ridge
wallet is light and sleek and industrial
it's designed to fit in your front
pocket unlike those bulky old school
wallets and make you look like you're
smuggling an 80s car phone in your back
pocket check it out there are over 30
colors including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash card
and
gold
dollars this is what they call the black
damascus only the finest for my front
pockets every ridge wallet comes with a
lifetime guarantee and they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it the wallets have over forty thousand
five star reviews it's made with an rfid
blocking technology that protects you
from those digital pickpocketers they
also have other cool products like this
commuter backpack it's weatherproof and
great for toting around a laptop so get
15 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge.com
new rockstars and use code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
and we should also look more closely at
jen's line in response to wong she also
seems that she might be aware of a
memory white spell occurring she says
that was highly unethical but it's not
really clear if she had any memory at
all of a pre versus post-memory wipe
spell reality and she's just remembering
it now or maybe she's just now learning
that the sorcerers did this and she's
responding to it in the moment saying
wait you wipe people's memories about
something that's highly unethical but
let's not forget that the reason this
whole exchange is in this episode is
that it's a meta joke by the she-hulk
writers poking fun at the crazier
logical leaps of the mcu in phase four
similar to that shout out they made a
tia mud from the eternals this isn't the
characters talking so much as it's
really the writers even if the she-hulk
writers are still learning how some nuts
on youtube will keep a transcript of
every word spoken ever in the mcu as a
kind of sacred gospel that must adhere
to the continuity of what these
characters could logically know but to
be fair to us we only do this because
the mcu told us their new big bad is
literally typing out everything everyone
says word for word so with that in mind
is there an in-universe answer to the
nature of the runes of cough call memory
wipe spell and how it works other than
it's messy well the new post-credits
scene of spider-man no way home's
re-release offers a straightforward
explanation with betty brant's senior
tribute video including a few photos and
videos that exclude peter parker but not
erased from the record the way hermione
obliviated herself from her parents
memories remember that depressing moment
but rather the simple explanation that
peter parker is now such a nobody to all
these people that the photographic
evidence of them just kind of awkwardly
frames him out and no one questions it
from his pack being turned to us to just
a pigeon flying in front of his face and
that's the photo they go with like i
think we often forget how confused and
traumatized and desensitized average
people are every day in the mcu these
people are constantly feeling like they
live in a simulated reality where
memories are blacked out from their
minds so maybe peter's yearbook photos
and state records still exist but when
people who would have any interest in
him look at his name and face they just
kind of zone out like a westworld host
doesn't look like anything to me and uh
speaking of jeffrey right does that
memory wipe spell also include the
watcher does it include he who remains
in kang well wong did say that the spell
wanders the borders between known and
unknown reality he does not say
realities plural unknown reality kind of
suggests that the spell might affect
reality in a specific way and also start
to bleed over into what lies just beyond
the border of this reality and right at
the other side of that glass wall is the
watcher it'd be kind of a bummer for
toby and andrew to go back to their
realities with no memory of the third
brother they have so at the end of the
day i think huang's status as sorcerer
supreme him giving steven permission to
do this spell and his request to leave
him out of it are reasons enough why
he's able to recall the spell being
conducted even if he doesn't remember
who the subject of that spell was and i
think this would elevate the sorcerer's
supreme to a power status of cosmic
beings like the watcher or at least
someone capable of communicating with
folks like that which makes sense if you
think about it the ancient one a
sorcerer's supreme had a divine insight
of steven strange's future when hulk
visited her back in 2012 years before
strange would begin practicing the
mystic arts and the sorcerers carry the
staff of the living tribunal suggesting
that someone who works there has a
direct line to the guy and as i've
speculated before the border between
known and unknown reality being
threatened by that spell could be one of
the reasons we are now in this messy mcu
with fourth wall breaking characters
like she-hulk she is after all a
character in a known reality speaking to
an unknown reality you can follow me on
tick tock instagram and twitter at boss
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
do
[Music]